you haven't seen my vagina
we'll get there takes time to warm up
hold up kim kardashian is getting very
comfortable and we need to know where
this conversation is going i was like
why not
on the season finale of hulu's the
kardashians the reality star brings her
man pete davidson on set and naturally
wants to introduce him to a special
co-worker pete come here you have to
meet paxy
paxi has worked with me as audio 14
years from keeping up with the
kardashians she knows everything about
me
she's probably seen my vagina
not more than you but she's but she's
probably seen it yeah kim and pete go
there and though we can't see him on
camera we hear the comedian loud and
clear she's probably seen my vagina
not more than you but she's but she's
probably seen it but it doesn't end
there the skim's founder gets even more
racy poking fun at her past you know the
sex tape with her ex ray j that she's
been trying to put behind her for years
takes time to warm up
to seeing my vagina
but you could look on the internet
i'm just kidding
it comes as no surprise that kim can
deliver a zinger after all she boldly
went there when she gets hosted saturday
night live when they asked uh i was like
you want me to host why i haven't had a
movie premiere in a really long time
i mean actually i only had that one
movie come out and no one told me it was
even premiering and from punchlines to
puckering up we have snl to thank for
kim and pete's romance
i mean i like you just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
as kim explained on the show their
relationship blossomed shortly after a
few days later i called the producer at
snl and i was like hey do you have
pete's number i text him i wasn't even
thinking like oh my god i'm gonna be in
a relationship with him i was just
thinking like heard about this bde need
to get out there like i need to just
like
jump start my
i was just basically dtf
fast forward to 2022 and they've been
together for nearly a year with things
getting more serious people always say
like oh he's so funny and it's like has
to do with how funny he is that's like
fourth on my list of why i like him
earlier this month the source told et
the pairs had a strong connection since
the beginning and back in april kim was
candid with e.t about their close bond
he's just super genuine
and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
[Music]